all right
felix bernard welcome thank you
the felix costume and the atlas costume
are now
getting the chance to play yeah
yeah felix and i met in the
no limits society nls group
and i'm really grateful because
he's been one of the strongest brightest
forces in there and so
this is gonna be a good one i'm excited
yeah thanks i'm excited too
let's start things off with felix by
asking
the classic question what are you
[Laughter]
interesting
yeah i will go with i am the spark of
the infinite
could you expand on that for us
well it is an ever expanding spark
[Music]
yes so currently it is expressing itself
uh through this um mind-body spirit
complex
called felix here on earth
um
yeah seems that this is a
one wandering soul
um
so kind of uh accelerated journey of
remembrance
of the true nature and all the good
things that go with this
that's a really good start
i love that start that's so great
okay so let's ask the follow-up to that
question
what are you not
well all of the above
yeah i mean
to me to me
like i can i can play with different
points of view of identity
so it's like i could say nothing
nothing is me like even even god
awareness of life
say it's not me
but then i see it also as um
it's still a bias i feel like to to go
too much into this not
me not me not me because in the end the
one
the one is all the one is everything and
actually i was just thinking about this
before our conversation
i was thinking about the absolutes and
all often
we use we use this term like
as in opposition to awareness or
god or whatever
and it can be definitely a useful
pointer
but then i feel it's important to to
bring it all back together
as as one if it's truly absolute it
can't be like
other than so
i don't know if it answers the question
yeah that's great i've really been
enjoying the
sort of there's so many of these
different
methods and procedures and strategies
but one that
i've really enjoyed is this two-step
where there's several two steps but
let's play with this two step
which is sort of the nettie nettie
to away from person consciousness
towards the more subtle
awareness that is impersonal and eternal
and then even transcending the first
attribute of awareness itself
in understanding what that absolute is
and is not and and then
so there's that netty nettie process and
then there's the
inclusion so step one is like netting
eddie and step two is this like radical
inclusion
in terms of i am the source of infinite
possibilities
and i am the impersonal eternal
awareness
and i am this felix and atlas costume
how does that resonate yes yes very much
and um i would say it's even like a
natural thing that happened
because
it's like the more we get disentangled
with the
personal construct the less there is a
bias
against anything so it's like naturally
once we're enough dissolve into
awareness then awareness doesn't have
anything
against the more relative expression so
it
naturally just comes back and includes
i love that point it's great the less
you become conditioned to
associate yourself with the distortions
and the
kinks and the twists and the 10 000
layers of those distortions kinks and
twists
that then you have less
bias you have less
service to self
i don't i don't feel as unsafe then
i feel less unsafe and so therefore as i
feel more safe
i feel more happiness more peace more
sachin ananda naturally
and therefore i also feel more of the
service to other
tendency of being the sun
radiating out peace happiness joy
abundance prosperity well-being
and that true nature just emanating more
so the less person the less bias
and the less also having to shove the
point of view
everywhere i really like the quote from
the retreat that
bentino said was that your
need to insert
your point of view will create holes in
the ship
[Music]
and richard condon said that the hardest
thing for a human
to let go of is their point of view
yeah but i would say it's even because
the point of view is the the personality
thing uh or maybe it's even beyond it
maybe even like the personality is a
byproduct of the point of view
so in a way we could even say like the
person
cannot let go of its point of view
because it has to come from
behind it beyond it it's distorted
twisted kinked point of view that
i'm a separate finite biological
egoic contracted energy that's separate
from everything
that doesn't know its true nature that
perspective with all those kinks and
distortions
is that point of view that is then
twisted and creates suffering versus
the whole point of infinity expressing
itself
as is in our
as is in our banner uh is that
you get this unique costume you have
endless
unique costumes and so the point is the
unique
costumes expressing themselves yeah
and the finding process all of it yeah
yeah and so in a way that also redeems
the the personal [ __ ] and all of
this because then it's
it's realized that it's it's the free
will of the creator it's
it's infinity expressing itself through
forgetting its true nature but that's
just one aspect of infinity
and that doesn't also suppress
the the seeking impulse to
to reach for more and more of the truth
so
can i create this back and forth between
the more
personal relative level and the more
absolute expanded
it's becoming more and more like a dance
or
a love affair it's each one trying to
get into the other one and then
again and again oh i like that
that also reminds me a lot of how
it really does
resonant at a deep level to
recognize the
arduous iteratory
process of landing on the mind
body spirit complex itself as the
vehicle
for the dancing slash love affair to
happen
as in it took many
creations and
densitorius sense to land on this sort
of
as in the law of one map that
third density play space
is so filled with dynamic fireworks
right now
yeah yeah and i mean even from
i think some of the things may be
selling a lot
of fun um i think that was also the hint
that the earth is also a very special
kind of
3d uh environment
why it's it's not always as a chaotic
and
[Music]
just like a whole mess of
all kind of different energies
but this makes it also a great place to
to learn and accelerate
so earth is a special environment and
the human is a special vehicle
yeah probably i don't know but i mean
yeah yeah i mean just the very
essence of being able to create
costumes that
that in itself is already mind blowing
for sure like this idea of
i am this like from the from the
infinite to
to to set up something where it can feel
more like i am here and not there
but still experience there but feel like
no this is this is me this is where i am
this is such a mystery this is such a
genius
invention
and i feel like it it resonates with
what we were saying earlier with the
fact that the more we relax
our biases the more we can actually
include the relative and
appreciate it i feel like when we're
very stuck in
in personhood we can have very much a
distaste
of of this individualization and
this me and all of this and feel like i
want to just dissolve and
just get done with this [ __ ]
but the more we actually dissolve the
more we like
actually this is fun this is great stuff
and yeah this is just a genius construct
like to
to imagine this it's like
so mind-blowing
to loop us with what we were just saying
and how you initially answered with what
are you
there is this
genius mysterious invention
mechanism of our source of infinite
possibility which
is this costume generator
and the costume generator is the sparks
of the infinite
and there's this funny-ass process where
the spark of the infinite
quote forgets
this is what our our nls
zoom call was like it was felix and i
giggling back and forth
the costume generator that was a funny
one yeah
you've heard of that right the random
number generator right in computer
science
yes yes yeah yeah
that's funny yes
this one can also seem quite random but
actually it's very precise and very
intentional
you know there's a will there's an
exploratory will
yes and then intelligence like
beyond anything we can imagine
i like the two words that
bentino used that the shift into
permanent alignment retreat he said that
intelligent infinity is intelligent and
it comprehends
[Music]
yes i've heard him use this uh
this term comprehend uh for the absolute
and the way it relates to awareness
i think it's uh it's quite good
and there's so much endless
possibility to explore
it becomes the coolest game in town
to undergo the most
dynamic crazy
exploratory ascensions that
have high levels of difficulty it's not
like planet earth is
some [ __ ] walk in a flower park
yeah it's like you
like you like walk through
the the
polarization between like massive
poverty and massive wealth and meanwhile
you just walk through with the smile on
your
hands yeah yeah
that's crazy yeah i mean it's
very it's very much like a war zone
and then
but then you go to southern france and
then you're chilling
yeah also but it depends on your point
of view because if
anywhere even where people are achieving
like from
a more awakened perspective it's still
like
i mean it's still full of love and it's
still full of [ __ ] so
it depends what you but yeah
what what i also wanted to add to this
like um
was on perspective is
is that actually um yeah
the more we awake and the more we we
realize that it's all taken care of
like the there is no
there is no worry to have it it's just
it's all happening by itself so then you
can
just walk through bullets and it's like
yeah whatever there's just this face
uh carrying us through
anything
and one of the
devil's advocate contrasting
perspectives to that which
i very much so agree with what
the felix costume here is sharing and
yet there are these other devil's
advocate costumes that would share like
well if we put the felix costume into
one of those
warzone rooms and started waterboarding
him and started cutting off
one each one of his fingers one at a
time
i am liberated from misery
yeah for sure it can get very intense
and um and i mean it's even part of the
play to
to forget to an extent even when we are
fairly awakened and
that's still this this aspect of getting
more into the mess and the murder and
and it's part of the process also to get
to this point where we take things very
seriously and
believe we are at stake and
and yeah after after afterward we look
back on it and
we laugh a bit about it a lot
and um and that's just part of the
of the expansion process it's
it's like again it's this kind of back
and forth and
it's again and again and again it allows
for deeper and deeper purification
because there are just things that that
would be so much harder to reach
if there was not this forgetting process
yeah yeah the the coolest
feature is that ability to veil itself
the veilless veil yeah
yeah that's such a mystery when you
really look at it it's like
what
but i've also learned that those
specifically
born into contexts that
have very enlightened parents or
in some of the indigenous traditions
they will
ensure that the child up from birth
knows itself as a spark of the infinite
and so that veiless veil never even gets
the chance to latch on with all these
layers of identity and
the contracted energy associated
with being a finite form
person consciousness and that's
also really really interesting is that
the
veils veil really only kicks in
for very unconscious ignorant
parenting and societal structures
[Music]
yes it's a kind of group consciousness
construct it's just a yeah it's a
kind of agreement we look it like from a
soul perspective it's like this bunch of
soul or agreeing like
okay we're going to bail ourselves and
just play
play with blindfold around basically
try to figure out what's what
[Music]
[Laughter]
blindfolded soul yeah that's pretty good
i was jumping in the pool yeah
yeah there was there was that funny
a funny meme i recently saw where it was
being
being asked again hey will you come and
help with the ascent of this planet
in the third density and it's like
okay
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
and and for sure i think we we have
experiences like this with
also uh smaller kinds of verbal reality
that we get into
but we can kind of sense that when we're
getting into a maybe a dancer there or
kind of some specific experience
and it's like there is the it can be a
bit
kind of back and forth like like
at the same time there is this love
impulse and this
also yeah this just the freedom the
carefree nature
of the one knowing itself it's like
up for anything but at the same time
there is this
more relative experience so like the
shit's gonna eat the fans like for sure
it's gonna get messy
and yeah often time i found myself in
kind of
this in between
well like the remnants of the
personality are kind of like
resisting it but then i see that from a
deeper perspective that's really what i
want
to give myself like this and to be
to be in service of love
well what's what is there cooler to do
than to be in service
of a planetary remembering
i don't know it's infinite so
there must be things cooler than that
i feel like i feel like being a jedi
and like sending these little like
fire flames underneath of people's asses
to help them remember
is like the coolest thing
but yeah there's infinite meaning
there's going to be so many other
possibilities
of what we experience right now
as this rock orbiting a star that has
8 billion units on it in a civilization
that has a very specific history that
has these vehicles that have two eyes
and four limbs and carbon-based dna
encoded 13.8 billion year evolutionary
is sent to get here
that whole story itself in the span of
eternity
is the grain of sand yeah yeah
and and even beyond that like the the
whole trajectory of the soul
across the seven density it's it's also
it's also
infinitely small and um it's
yeah it's one thing that bentino uh
shared an example of uh from the the law
of one
but there are clues about like
nice density being uh
coming back to to help us
like with the ascension process and
there is some description of them
yeah though and those are really
fascinating
yeah good those that jump between
universes
yeah like
and and like following that kind of
thread we can
expand like more and more and more and
realize like it's also infinite in
this dimension and it's like whoa
[ __ ]
and it i i love how it puts everything
in such a vast perspective it's like
yep it's like there's only now and it's
infinite
yeah there's that
you'll probably i'll pull this one up
over over here for us
um this the
oh i can't
i can't get it too too large
uh because it will blur a bit but i can
get it about that large so let's uh
let's showcase it
exactly i love this one i think this one
came in the chat
yeah yeah be here a couple times
which way should we go how long will it
take to get there where is
that how far away is it how do we get
there
that was me five years ago and even four
years ago and three years ago and two
years ago
and like last year i started getting it
and i was like okay i think i'm starting
to get it
this shit's so funny yeah
i mean what's great also that is that
during
all these questioning it's just like
here it is
yeah and and really to
to have a who
have had
as a child growing up to have had a
part of the pedagogy of the education
be about me being a spark of the
infinite
this is a costume generated by the
infinite i have
made the decision to come as a mind body
spirit complex
for unleashing some sort of a
contribution
in the planetary
leela that play the divine cosmic play
that's unfolding here
and yeah nobody ever [ __ ] taught me
sachit anand that's cool
yeah for sure
yeah i think it's it's interesting to
contemplate this thing because
i can also see how um
having denser like in the sense of
more daily experience you know childhood
can also be of great benefits then
um great because i
i've also um
yeah i've been to to a particular
community which is quite spiritual
in nature and um there were examples of
uh
children being born in this community
and um so it was not like
fully enlightened or whatever but there
were definitely some aspects of
um watch what you said about
um teaching the children
that they are spark of the infinite and
so on and so
um these children growing up
uh could have some difficulty also to
relate to the
the wilder the wider world and then
yeah all the mess that goes on and
so yeah
there are different aspects of it it's
like um
it just creates different experiences
altogether
have you heard this one
it goes
right there it goes the brighter
the brighter the flame the deeper the
shadow
and i like that one a lot yet
something to remember about that is if
you get out
so the brighter the flame
if you get out of that deeper shadow
so yes yeah yeah because
uh because you see the locks
on that 3d matrix grid
of governments and propaganda and
politicians and economic machinery and
fast food and high fructose corn syrup
and all this type of
nonsensical [ __ ]
that we created those
locks are like [ __ ] massive boulders
the size of skyscrapers
attached to our ankles and so
you know sitting there and chipping away
the
at the illusory skyscraper boulder
this is ridiculous
[Laughter]
um okay this would probably be a good
time to
uh to ask you about your calling
people experiencing absolute love yes
tell us about this
so so i think we i've i've talked about
it
already quite a bit
um but what does it look like
for people
experiencing absolute how does the felix
costume
contribute to people experiencing
absolute love
yeah i'm not sure um
like definitely it's a working process
in progress
yeah i mean the sense the sense of it is
that it can look
all kind of way because like
the nature of absolute means that
it's not restricted to one kind of
expression
and uh it's definitely some aspect
of what i've been enjoying in my life
through a very
uh different kinds of expression and
different environment
where i express myself and so i
i i feel like it's it's quite a big part
of this calling is to be very
flexible and to to find
to find a way to love in in all
circumstances basically
so that's that's a good um starting
point
that's huge because it gives you
flexibility
same thing with me with people
experiencing truth that's one of my main
favorite parts about it is the
flexibility that's associated with it
because as a jedi we can sort of
navigate
across the
spectrum of people experiencing
absolute love or truth
and i love how you give that definition
of absolute as no
limits i think that's really a good way
to
to put it yeah usually people put the
definition as
highest absolute as highest but i like
the definition as no limits that's a
good one too
not restricted
yeah for me just it just has to be
all-inclusive
and i mean the the word love also points
to this it's really
like it's about everything
but at the same time i feel that the the
absolute
world also brings a kind of more focused
energy on more
because i've been playing also with the
term infinite love
and uh i've been enjoying it also quite
a bit but it feels
it gives it with infinite love it feels
sometimes a bit too
imbalanced to what love and to
to to just open
with absolute love it feels like there's
there's
more balance between like feminine
masculine or love and wisdom
but that that's what i've been playing
with actually quite recently
yeah infinite love feels too imbalanced
that's pretty interesting
yeah almost like
for some reason infinite love might
sound like in the la of one maybe a
little bit like the overzealous
fourth density and then the absolute
love can maybe feel like it's balanced
out with wisdom in the sixth unity
something like that it's kind of it's
kind of interesting
yeah yeah but that's cool though that
even though
yeah even the word itself to
to be at that level we just did a video
on
callings like what is your calling to
help
the audience with generating that
divine process and
you're at a place of such nuance where
you're actually going through these
really strong different words and so to
get to that point i think is also really
good
and it's really helpful yeah yeah and
it's an interesting process because um
in the end it's not about the world
it's what they're pointing to but still
like we we get to feel the nuances with
the world and actually maybe
if someone else was using the same words
it would have a different meaning and a
different vibration
so it's also a very individual process
it's just like something um
yeah that's also interesting somebody
whose calling
is infinite love could feel the opposite
like they could yeah yeah yeah that's
interesting
where they don't feel as much resonance
with absolute love that's so cool
yeah yeah somebody
could be like some
say something similar about how
experiencing truth
isn't as resonant for them for example
corey
malone uh his is people experiencing
magic and so for him magic is like
the truth at a higher level and for me
truth is the word that i
chose for that yeah so it's kind of yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i think in the end um our calling
is
pretty much always like our own specific
taste
of the one so it's
just and it's quite fascinating because
it's still
kind a kind of bias but it's so subtle
um it's a it's like the bias of our soul
or
a very like a very deep and very
intimate
uh aspect of ourselves but it's it's
still not
to pull the full self
actually sri aurobindo and the mother
mirror alfasa used to call it the soul
angle yeah yeah yeah
yeah i like the way of describing it
it's resonant
we had this really funny moment where
i feel like yo this is
will resonate what i'll share we had
this really funny moment in the
one of the nls videos where
i was walking us through this
spontaneous just guided
abiding as ineffable perfection
and then there was like a break
in the audio for for a moment
and then one of the other sort of
members decided to in a sense
just be like let's move and talk about
something else
and then and then and then you
and i we're both i feel like
really analytically
solve what was happening with how
there's that
that impulse to move away from the
abiding as
inevitable perfection we started
giggling and then
and then we got it back to them
yeah yeah and definitely i can also feel
it in myself like this
urge to move us me too
yeah yeah what tell us about your
process with that
fun
this
this ineffable perfection just
recognizing and abiding
rather than well what's the next book
that i have to read what's the next
antigen that i have to take what's you
know
oh i am already what i seek you know
yeah yeah so how has that been like for
you
like what what do you do do you have a
process of
of just kind of defocusing or how does
how does that process look like for you
cool question
i mean the funny thing is that in the
end um
it's beyond all methods
so we can use methods but it's it's only
a crutch
it's our permission slip or whatever we
want to call it it's
but it can be useful definitely
i mean yeah it depends
um many times it's
it's just like there is enough momentum
that it's just
happening by itself oh even saying that
it's
it's still suggesting that it could not
happen
but um but yeah there are also
definitely times where it feels like
there is more of a specific
um method angle that works
best for me
that is yeah so for example uh
yesterday i had a great time with um
yeah i had a very wonderful meditation
with um
starting with um
actually yeah coming from the absolute
maybe using this pointer like uh um
stay as the absolute
[Music]
so this is a very important one for me
really allows to to let go of all
identification with
what appears and so but then
during that meditation also what kicks
it what
what kicked in was um
[Music]
yeah actually that's a good uh
expression of my calling also because
what was activated was also very much
this
love energy this this focus in the heart
and then again like seeing it
from the absolute that is the the
dissolution of the
identification with even the most
intimate
uh sense of love
and so this process gets very
got very intense and but in a very soft
and
gentle way was actually very
very beautiful because um in the past
i've
definitely had some times where i'm
focusing on the absolute but more
imbalanced
in a way
yeah like too much trying to get to
somewhere or
too much like a sense of
[Music]
just a tension around that um
which in itself is um
is due of still some identification with
the appearance
because if you're truly the absolute
then there is not this
this contraction this
so yeah but but for example this is more
focused about the absolutely it doesn't
necessarily happen that often for me
[Music]
i love the coming from the absolute
method
and yeah i feel like
there is a couple ways to in a sense at
least from
how i understand it coming from
there's like coming from i am
already the absolute indescribable
ineffable perfection
right here right now yeah
and then there's this other sort of way
which is kind of like we talked about at
the beginning with this
sort of netty netty approach from the
person consciousness
to becoming the impersonal eternal
awareness to becoming
even getting that last thorn of
awareness even out of the way
and then there's also sort of coming
from the absolute and then
in a sense using the first attribute of
awareness and then
using it's almost like when we simulate
a dream at night
in a sense because when you simulate the
dream at night
you simulate out the observer and
the environment for the observer that
kind of a thing
yeah it's also always simulating the
dream
during the day yeah
i love it
so there's almost like the one kind of
here and now is the
absolute the two is kind of the nettie
nettie
to absolute and the third one is like
absolute simulating
observer in reality
yeah that's pretty interesting
here i can uh
oops nope not that one i want to do this
one
let's see if i can do multiple i've been
trying to see if i can do multiple
so there's that one
it's okay so i'll i'll still i'll play
around with it to see if i can do
multiple but so that's the second one
and then
and then there's this one oh no
not that there we go
yeah pretty interesting
yeah different different
toys to play with
oh these are great toys
yeah divine toys
the divine toys i love it
wow the divine toys that's an
interesting one
yeah and this is sort of what you could
say is
the
after
years of analysis
of a meta pattern in a sense
of the landscape of mystics and
yogis and retreats and entheogens and
aphorisms and books and all these things
the meta pattern is you get to these
divine toys
[Music]
and people get to different divine toys
but the general idea
is that
this is ineffable perfection
you're so already free
[Laughter]
oh my god
yeah it just becomes we
[Music]
it's like this balance between
which are all which is ultimately one
but it's kind of this balance between
this
sort of like buddha like
with like the atlas
like planetary enlightenment
you know type thing yeah so it's
cool to merge them
in in bentino's worlds
it would be like the mirror with
shepherding
qualities
i was i was i was thinking about this
like
you know bentino mentioned this during
the the shift also
into permanent alignment where he said
that
you can be awakened and
run several
successful businesses around
planetary enlightenment and maximizing
the collective's potential
and that really resonates with me but
then that also gets balanced with
like anurag gupta talked about on the
mirror talks podcast
this business reduction program
yeah yeah
i [ __ ] love that one
that's actually such a wonderful thing
is to
to witness different like decently
enlightened beings
and to see like the
the difference in expression that can
come
of that same state
it's um it's also a kind of
mind [ __ ] and opening more and more to
the mystery of it all and
and we we all get to be our own unique
expression
of that which ties us to the spark of
the infinite
yeah did you ever learn about the
did you ever learn about this
it's the sufi metaphysic
wadat al-wujud
the unity of all finding
so like we were talking about throughout
the episode that you have that
very fractally style sparking
of the infinite that then has this
process
of what is my nature
and then like you just described a
moment ago
you'll never get to the end of all of
the different
ways that the spark of the infinite
communes
finds recognizes itself
so the the cessation and the style and
the taste of the seeking and the finding
that kind of a thing yeah
and so that's what the wadata ujud means
that's the unity of all of that finding
so you have all of these different you
know this
felix costume and this atlas costume and
the anurak costume and whatnot which is
which is why they're expressed
differently where anurag has this like
business reduction
program right type thing
yeah and then and then we get to
interact with each other and
and reflect and like
and that's why the nls is such a great
place to hang it's like there's so
many interaction at a very high level
it's
it's iphone it's such a
world-class container for
those that have awakened and want to
purify themselves
and ascend more rapidly with
others of similar levels of awakening
and then build with them to
ignite that global awakening and that's
been
the the mission that all of these
callings fit
with which is
ultimately what we all came to do we all
came
to rapidly remember
and then to catalyze remembering
[Music]
yeah and it's like it's like we are
resonators
so the more we remember the more we are
just broadcasting that remembrance
and then the more we gather together as
resonator the more
we amplify these signal images and
and get it more precise and
the great stuff that was the first time
i think i
heard in that amplification process you
used the word
resonator i like that it's interesting
we amplify as a resonator
yeah it's cool i like that a lot
yeah i think it goes well so with the
idea of purification
of the being a vessel for the one and
the more we empty our [ __ ] the more we
can actually
resonate at that high frequency very
pristinely
and then it also propagates around
empty your [ __ ] so you can resonate
pristinely
do you have a big cloud in front of
the sunlight or have you liberated
yourself from the
cloud you know
and yeah and the and the yeah the cloud
was an illusion
yeah yeah maybe we could say both
because there's still there's still some
degree of veiling
there is yeah yeah you you would die
if you yeah i mean were naturally died
because
you not like
you would literally explode like this
whole mind body spirit complex would
explode
if you felt everything at the same time
or something yeah
yeah i mean we could also say that it
never really existed so it
just stopped being generated
but yeah to go back to your question
yeah
um yeah i mean definitely there
are some there there is
purification ongoing and uh
um some waves sometimes it feels
much more bright and expensive and
delightful and sometimes a more
contracted state
and and
that that allows for the deeper and
deeper
uh purification and that that's also one
thing that came up when you
brought this thing about uh the brighter
the flame the deeper the shadow
i think it can also work in the sense of
like the deeper we
we can go in the [ __ ] and transmute it
then also the deeper our realization
the brighter we can shine
which is why tomorrow for mark's
accept yourself 2.0 program i'm having a
call with him to
explore becoming a fit
and a part of that because it's really
interesting
undergoing the process of even though
you have
already underwent such a process of
accepting
your ineffable perfection already and
have become the creator
as a gnostic being they're still
like you describe this process of
really refining and purifying that level
of knowing and accepting yourself to
where you can
really really unleash
super high pristine yeah
yeah and i mean the way i see it it's
it's infinite
like um it's also the sense that i get
from people that seem
more ahead than me in this past it's
like
that there's no end to it and um i think
also what bench in your shell recently
is like
to a great extent like suffering can be
um 100 we can
we can stop generating this kind of
experiences
but but i think like pain and
contraction
it's it's another story it's i think it
can
keep having some relevance
and um yeah it's also
so beautiful part of the process to get
more amber with that and to also
accept and embrace it even and
see the value in it
in the shift he says
i'm a self-purification engine
and that's also very inspirational
because it it really boils down
to it that first in
the law of one know yourself except
yourself become the creator the first
point of know yourself really
at the level of frame by frame by
frame by frame where am i full of [ __ ]
repeatedly
and that in itself is like
that's really inspirational being a
self-purification engine
at the level of the frames and that's
yeah that's its own like that's a beast
that's like a lifelong beast to tackle
or you can say it's the love affair
oh yeah there you go beautiful
and it just keeps getting deeper and
deeper and more
intimate and more cheerful
gosh i love that it's kind of reminds me
of the savage and the saint
you know you got there's like this like
vigilance
and love affair like yeah yeah yeah
it's cool yeah yeah
because it's contrast it's all about
that beautiful
both monist but also yin yang
the contrast it's so so contrastfully
beautiful
we're the absolute same
and also we are the beautiful
s creative
costume sparks
yes exactly
yeah i don't know if there is anything
to add to this
let's put that one up also
absolute same and creative costume
sparks
yeah so
boom yeah that's that's a pretty good uh
that's a pretty good wrap
yeah i think so yeah it was gorgeous
it was really smooth felix yeah that was
really really really smooth yeah
yeah thanks thanks for inviting me and
yeah
you you really have you have a
this anchored ineffable perfection
resonance and also
the understanding at a level that's
makes this tennis
between the costumes of the i am very
facial very easy
yeah thanks i appreciate you
yeah great great friend to to play
tennis with you
i know the i am loves playing tennis
with itself
eight billion tennis units
units hitting un
uncountable tennis balls back and forth
with one another
like you look at the internet and it's
like so many
players and tennis balls happening in
understanding the one great in the one
great player understanding itself
yeah we should definitely we should
definitely do a
uh um even a felix and
uh vincent atlas one that could be fun
yeah yeah i'm actually curious to listen
to
you guys conversation
he was so good yeah it is great too
i love it
all right all right beautiful thanks
everyone for tuning in
we adore you we're very grateful thank
you
if the video brought you value give it a
like it helps the algorithm subscribe to
the channel if you haven't yet
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below on all the topics that we
talked about
and share the video with people that you
feel like this would resonate with
and help in their recognizing
and also felix is there a good place for
people to
follow you on the interwebs um
[Music]
i'm not really active on social media or
anything so
[Music]
i'm not really at anything yeah cool
sounds good looks like there will be a
follow-up
if yeah if it resonates felix might um
become a social media superstar and
we'll put some links to
love it i love it all right thanks
everyone for tuning in
i'm gonna end the broadcast you and i
will stick in here okay
all right all right bye everyone bye bye
matchdog